Security
is hard.
Authentication
User management, you guessed it,
hard. So let's make our Portainer lives a
little bit simpler
by using an authentication
method that we know and we trust. Today,
we'll take a look at configuring Portainer
to use GitHub
and Google. In just a few clicks, you
could turn on single sign on and never
have to worry about manually provisioning users again.
Let's take a look at our Portainer instance.
So here we are on the Portainer homepage.
You'll see here that I have added my
local Docker instance, my Docker desktop on macOS,
where we can click and see all the
usual information that we expect.
Stacks, images, networks, yada yada yada.
However, for me to access this Portainer instance,
I used local authentication.
You can see here in the admin user
and if I pop back here, I log
in with my username and password.
If we go to settings and click authentication,
we have the ability here
to select between internal authentication that we're using
now,
LDAP,
active directory or and
OAuth.
We're gonna focus today on OAuth because this
is the authentication method
that most people will find handy.
We can click on OAuth here and we'll
see that we have a couple of toggles
that we can change.
One, do we even want to use single
sign on?
Spoiler alert, yeah, we do. Managing individual users
sucks.
You then have a decision to make. Do
you want to enable automatic
user provisioning?
This just means that if you want anyone
within your organization,
anyone with an account on your external
authentication provider, single sign on provider,
to access your Portainer, that can be configured.
And to do so, you configure a default
team.
For today, we're not gonna use that.
The other setting you can enable is automatic
team membership.
So giving people access to teams by default
based on claims within the external authentication provider.
And we will do a follow-up video where
we take a look at automatic user provisioning
and automatic team membership.
But today, we're gonna keep this short and
sweet.
We're gonna focus on setting up Google and
GitHub authentication
for your Portainer instance.
Let's start with GitHub.
Like most OAuth configurations, you need a client
ID and a client secret. To get these,
you can go to your GitHub organization
where you can click settings,
scroll all the way down to developer and
select OAuth apps.
Now you'll see I already have a few,
but we're going to create a new one.
I'm going to call this Portainer
in production.
And it doesn't matter what your homepage is
set to. So I'm just going to say
google.com.
For the authorization callback, this will need to
be a URL that resolves to your Portainer
instance.
Because I'm running this locally, I'm going to
use local host 9 4 4 3.
From here, we can click register.
Oh, and make sure you get the protocol
right.
This gives us a client ID like so.
Let's pop back over to Portainer and drop
it in. Next, we need a client secret.
So we'll click generate new client secret,
but you'll have to provide some authentication to
GitHub.
This secret will never be shown to you
again, so make sure you store it at
a nice safe place.
We drop this in like so
and hit save.
And that's it. You've now configured your Portainer
instance to authenticate
with a GitHub application.
Now before we log out and test our
GitHub authentication,
we need to do one more thing.
Because automatic user provisioning is disabled and automatic
team membership is disabled,
we have to go to users and add
Rawkode.
This is my GitHub username.
From here, I can say I
am an administrator.
Let's pop that in here to authentication.
Click save just to confirm that everything looks
alright
before
finally
logging out.
Now you'll see right away that it'll log
me straight back in. And if you caught
the little flickers, you would have seen the
Portainer logo
that detected
that I'm not unauthenticated.
Now that we've logged out of Portainer,
it's redirected us to a GitHub page.
What's happened is we browse to local host
9443.
Portainer has detected that we're no longer logged
in. We directed us to get up to
see if it can get authentication details,
where I've logged out and authentication has failed.
So
we can say, hey. Let's log in to
get up. And you'll see that our continue
with the Portainer in production application is here.
We click sign in,
verify our TOTP,
and now we're being asked to authenticate the
Portainer in production app against GitHub.
We can click authorize,
we'll be redirected,
and logged in to Portainer.
And that is GitHub authentication.
Now word of warning, this is easy to
mess up. And in fact, I've done it
a few times.
You can turn off the hide authentication
hide internal authentication
prompt.
This just means that if you do mess
up any settings, you can come back here
and log out.
We'll sign out of GitHub.
Go back to Portainer.
And now we have an option. Log in
with GitHub or use internal authentication.
So if you do mess up, don't worry.
Just remember to check that box. And that
is external authentication with GitHub.
So next, let's take a look at Google.
So we go back to the settings authentication
screen where we can select Google. Now it's
important to note that you can only have
one of these enabled at any given time.
When we select Google, we lose GitHub.
We're going to delete the client ID.
The client secret is already hidden, and we're
gonna head over to Google Cloud.
From Google Cloud, you're gonna want to go
to API and services and credentials.
The easy way to get there is in
the search bar to type OAuth, and that's
the second hit.
From here, we say create credentials where we
want to create an OAuth client ID.
Now we can see that we are web
application,
and we'll call this Portainer
in production.
And I'm just gonna add Google to that
to avoid any confusion or ambiguity with the
GitHub client.
From here, we can add the authorized JavaScript
origin.
We're gonna use local host nine four four
three. And in fact, we're going to copy
this for the authorized redirect URLs
too.
We click create and much like the GitHub
one, we get our client ID.
We can hit copy, pop back,
and paste.
Next, we're going to copy the secret
where we head back to Portainer
and paste.
From here, we click save. Much like the
GitHub, we have to pre add our user.
Go back to users.
Now we're going to add david at Rawkode
dot academy. Why? That is my Google username.
And I'm going to make me
an administrator.
Now we can go and log out. So
let's click log in with Google.
We get presented with the account switcher,
and you can see that it's going to
continue to the Rawkode Academy because that's the
Google Cloud project name that we should.
We select the user,
and we're logged in.
This is just a short video today showing
you how to improve your security posture
by removing some headaches from managing your Portainer
instance.
Nobody likes managing individual user account.
You're probably already using GitHub,
Google, or some other authentication provider. So just
let that do the heavy lifting and manage
your Portainer users too. In the next video,
we'll take a look at automatic team membership
and automatic account creation
using those two little checkboxes we avoided in
the first video.
So come back and see how to go
a little deeper with Portainer's external authentication.
We'll see you in a couple of days.
Until then, have a great day.